l'événement de la rentrée par il
attendait s'entend après la capitale
organisera les jeux olympiques d'été en
2024 annonce officielle suivie en direct
au vélodrome nationale l'enceinte est
l'un des quatre sites de l'agglomération
choisie pour accueillir à des épreuves
c'est vraiment une explosion joie on l'a
senti lors de l' annonce est maintenant
l aventure commence une aventure
commence c'est une aventure historique
et ça va être passionnant de vivre cette
période
dernière grande échéance électorale de
l'année les sénatoriales les
républicains conduits par est gérard
larcher réélu ensuite président de la
chambre remporté cinq des six sièges
possibles l'un est obtenu par michel
laugier touché par la loi sur le
non-cumul il a dû quitter ses mandats de
président de saint quentin en yvelines
et de maire de montigny le bretonneux
c'est un mélange de fierté et de bonheur
et de tristesse aussi parce que j'ai là
un petit peu dit si pâle qui est
dynamique cette fin d'année a été
également marquée par le retrait de deux
femmes politiques yvelinoise toutes deux
anciennes ministres la socialiste
catherine tasca ne se représentait pas
aux sénatoriales est la fondatrice du
parti chrétien démocrate christine
boutin démissionné de sa fonction de
conseillère départementale elle
assistait à sa dernière séance le 21
octobre à versailles après 35 ans de
mandat c'était très beau c'était très
très beau que je voulais absolument rien
mais j'ai été très très touché par
l'authenticité des réactions mes
collègues c'est un changement qui de
fait est douloureux parce que moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé le sénat octobre mois des
frondes politique mobilisation notamment
des élus pour le maintien de la ligne à
18 dans les yvelines c'est aussi le mois
des changements de visage jean-luc
ourgaud devient maire de montigny le
bretonneux
jean michel fourgous édiles d'elancourt
prend la tête de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ouverture
prônée quatre vice présidents seront
accordés à l'opposition de gauche qu'on
puisse tous partir dans le même sens
voilà donc c'est la première tâche qui
m'incombe dans le dans les quatre
semaines à venir
du nouveau également à l'université
versailles saint quentin en yvelines le
professeur alain but est élu président
il succède au professeur didier
guillemot démissionnaire pour raisons de
santé fin 2010 est marquée également par
la révélation de l'affairé van stein
quelques semaines plus tard en novembre
le centre d'information sur le droit des
femmes et des familles des yvelines fête
ses 35 ans la parole se libère mais déjà
depuis plusieurs années on voit qu'il ya
de plus en plus de manifestations enfin
de dénonciation de faits on le voit au
niveau du nom augmentation de nos
victimes aussi des exploits et des
performances sportives en nombre de
records du monde à 82 ans jeannette
augusto réalisé 28 km 226 en une heure
sur la piste du vélodrome nationale 24
heures de nage en apnée pour randy
cabreira davila saint cyr l'école pour
le téléthon en décembre la 6e place à la
transat jacques vabre pour le skipper
versaillais tanguy de lamotte qui a
permis de sauver 25 enfants malades du
coeur et puis les encours toit a dit la
mohammadi qui conserve sa ceinture
européenne de boxe lors du mail et 24 au
vélodrome champion d'europe dans les
yvelines grande fierté et encore merci
pour ceux qui le soutiennent
de la joie mais aussi de la tristesse
avec des disparitions le maire de
chevreuse claude juneau fin août
l'acteur jean rochefort en octobre qui
laisse un souvenir fort à auffargis où
il possédait un haras et bien sûr johnny
hallyday en décembre le chanteur a
habité les yvelines mais aussi donné un
concert et l'encours en 1990 je dis qu'à
habitué au grand palais des sports 20 30
50 mille ans qu ils ont bloqué à 2000
places pour des raisons de sécurité des
gens
à la toute fin de l'année les yvelines
embarque dans une galaxie très lointaine
avec la sortie de star wars 8 et c'est
le petit village de gars lui qui crée
l'événement en proposant une exposition
tricot insolites autour de l'univers de
la saga une exposition qui se poursuit
jusqu'à fin janvier l'embarquement pour
2018 est enclenché